but there comes to a point where you've
cut everything you know the welfare
state is cut to a bare minimum enough
they cut that back further it's going to
be and it looks like they might you're
going to see real it's going to be bad
right and it's difficult to cut stuff
there but then then how do you make the
rich richer how do you keep making the
rich richer and you know the only assets
left are the houses of the middle class
now you know so
it comes to a point where you know you
need to hit those people if you want to
make the rich richer anymore you know
because the economy is not growing so
the only way the rich get richer is
taking assets from the rest of us you
know we've cut their taxes we've cut you
know government services
um and now I think the conservatives are
in this bind where it's like
how do you keep that machine going
without hitting your core of other base
which is homeowners you know and I think
they're I think they're really stuck
here because
you know
they
the only thing you can do here to
prevent an economic collapse is tax the
rich and it's like their reason to be
that they can't do that